un petit mot sur l'eurovision la chanson
de tom hleb a été dévoilé et alors
l'info c'est que s'appelle the best
thing i l'info c'est que malheureusement
dès que la chanson est sortie à quinze
chansons qui sont sortis pour le moment
ça a tout de suite chuté chez des
bookmakers on n'a jamais vu ça ils à 2%
d'intentions de ba de chances de
remporter en mai prochain à rotterdam
alors il a dû commerce pour orchestrer
un petit peu tout ça mais je sais pas
nous entende et chroniqueur celle ci moi
j'étais en lisant l'afuzi s'est passé je
n'en sont qu'aux rumeurs ça dérange
personne à droite mais si tu peux
souvent des conneries c'était donc les
infos des chroniqueurs autant pour moi
et donc on était sur l'eurovision myriam
de quoi s'agit-il
alors comme il a été vu par tous elle
est là la chanson de best in me de tom
l'aide c'est plutôt bon pour écouter
juste la chanson alors écoutez ça
je
[Musique]
voilà j'étais très court mais suffisant
et donc d'autres bref elle n'a pas elle
n'a pas rencontré un grand succès même
le ministre de la culture a dit que ça
lui casser les oreilles de tendance
renouer bref une vraie catastrophe
dernier enfin dans les derniers chez les
bookmakers qui de l'eurovision
bref là ça va ça va très très mal donc
je conseille à tom lot de réorchestrer
effectivement comme vous il a le droit
parce que je cesse sa chanson comme
d'autres l'avaient fait l'année dernière
le grand gagnant de l'eurovision duncan
laurence avait réorchestré société
dernier aussi les brevets et puis
surtout il avait fait un clip où il
était à poil donc moi je conseille à
templeuve qui est plutôt pas mal de le
faire oui mais basé sur son physique
mais semaine il a dit alors lui il a dit
pascal victoire quand la chanson été
signé à la chanson a été écrite par les
suédois qui est peu fournie à ce truc là
qui avait gagné kessel nommé s'appelle
laurine voilà c'est ça et moi j'adorais
la chanson effectivement amir élus se
sont dit tiens on va on va enlever un
petit peu de recrues stration d'en faire
une balade un peu
pendant ce temps c'est pas un succès de
succès mais lui a dit dans la presse
sébastien je refuse justement de miser
sur mon physique ou par envoi torse nu
tous a dit que sur la chanson c'est
dommage parce que c'est ce qui donne au
mieux sa non merci
j'avais pas vu qu'il n' ont été ici
alors les sa bête
je vais vous et mines on n'a pas de
chance de gagner vous qui étiez en live
dans la salle pour comme un enfant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai présenté le dernier parce qu'il est
magnifique elisabeth concours n'a aucune
chance de gagner pourquoi parce que
j'aime pas trop la chanson parce que
j'aime pas trop le mec non plus il est
beau ou pas n'ont pas trop eu la dure
aux yeux verts mais bon mais c'est pas
suffisant pour gagner
mathieu oui ça ne lâchera pas vous tapez
mathieu attend juste mathieu après tout
moi je pense que vous vous trompez pas
ce que la chanson d'accord les les nuls
on est d'accord mais c'est nous qui
votons à l'eurovision c'est tous les
pays de l'est sont pour la plupart et ça
correspond parfaitement le genre de
variétés qu'ils écoutent
on n'est pas là pour si vous présentez
un truc très bien ou alors qu'il va être
au second degré ça va être comme l'année
dernière on a beaucoup travaillé qu'à
venir ne peuvent pas mal traduits et ça
qu'on avait des pros de l'eurovision
donc pas rentrer dans tous les détails
financiers et tout mais là ce qu'ils
nous ont dit oui hier c'est on risque
d'avoir comme l'allemagne et dernière de
frôler les héros des guerres se trouve
juste rajouté action comme elle est là
pour le moment on peut être entre avant
dernier et dernier
non juste un détail le directeur
artistique et dr cette chanson s'appelle
philippe savry fc la personne ses
producteurs indépendants que plus de
tubes ces dix dernières années en france
le seul atout qui pourrait donner une
chance mais je pense quand la zéro c'est
la bêtise des paroles je passerai
entendu en anglais visionnez le toit qui
écoute les paroles non mais donc c'est
pour ça que ça faisait gagner et elle me
convenait de chances de gagner à cause
de ces ions quoi alors oui pourquoi pas
le genre de gars que tu as mis non
[Rires]
si on salue de vous dire que tu n'es au
bureau est d'accord je trouve qu'il fait
un peu boys band esseulé quoi en gros
voilà il est sympathique il est une
bonne terre désolée je trouve ça dommage
parce que la musique la trouve pas après
moi j'suis pas du tout choquée que ce
soit en français en anglais la cd vieux
réactionnaire qui trouvent que parce
qu'on est en france on doit chanter en
français je pousse ta voix malin d'avoir
mélangé
bon après j'ai envie qu'on gagne mais ça
que dieu me regarde le clip il dit c'est
pas moi sur tout et rag le mec à la
caméra fait mais là je reconnais qu'il
faut tout revoir un petit peu en tôle
eurovision pas hyper moderne un dernier
mot on change qu'être un gars vous avez
un âge un peu trop avancé je pense que
vous êtes à la hauteur de chefs chanteur
qui est juste exceptionnelle y est
magnifique super bien chez moi je vous
fais le pari quittera dans les cinq
premiers dans son agence en incluant
ceux où les espaces non trop non pas
comme non
il a mûri des boss quand elle parle même
siffle jamais refusé toute oeuvre tout
rapprochement avec un de mes influences
a jamais discuté dans son agence a
annoncé pas couché avec ses demandes que
tu as aussi ça